what am I supposed to do on tv so what
am I supposed to do there what to keep people yes but i
can also entertain people via my
platform i really want to have
rtl2 audience or
the rtl audience which is
kind of hanging 24/7 every day and focuses on families
look what
else to say about monte one of the most successful
video streams ever in germany
and i would have been at his house listening to
his story trying to
understand was success comes from here
and you can do all that now monte
hallodri which is probably so that people
unfortunately too often it's like
that
it's kind of like a temple yes if
I like to be alone for myself
so to say where to visit
yes the way here was for you now
yes that is known somehow not
necessarily mapped out you  you have
definitely had a very winding
career and today you
have to say to yourself and everyone else also says that you are
indisputably the greatest  te live stream in
germany yes yes based on
numbers but
since you have already played through the whole game it
is not so yes i am
definitely one of the biggest streamers
i would say for one of the biggest
streamers of the  followers pay on
switch the size year it can't
buy anything from what you need commitment
yes yes no no that but
you always get how should i say
so now comes over as a bit
snooty when you
need it like that  if other people say that
about you okay but i'm
just a switch type
but tell me very practically how many
people are there live when you go live
you i think it's different like with a
podcast episode if
you now follow a  special guest you have more
streams on your podcast you if you have
someone you maybe not so
relevant or not so well known then
less and sauce occurs even if you have
an s  you have a game that is all the rage
right now and is in the hype and the
streams can sometimes have a
hundred thousand viewers or
more or you say
average numbers are around
30-35 thousand people a week and towards the
weekend when the people are here  are at
home and where then takes care 50,000 times
depending on the phase which games you play
what kind of program plays yes you
are you are actually
live every day with a few exceptions no no no
no no well yes i'm also
live every day but
then  must be
looking for a game that i come live every day
currently i
would say only three four times a week but then
we are also talking about three four times a week
for 50 hours each yes yes it seems like
a full-time job
yes you can say exactly  so say if
a hobby well i have us
nature speak yes the job is just me
so of course it's my job but it
's still a very relaxing  nter job
so i still see more as a
hobby just let it go
accordingly when you started
you have now caught from the
background doing an apprenticeship i
think
as a retail salesman in the tree
i know correctly also completed yes
also weakened although two weeks
before the end  resigned but i will still take
the exam so i was still admitted
for the exam and i
passed the exam yes and why quit
yes there were differences the teaching profession
a long way off wasn’t what i
wanted and i had a lot of
headaches with it  with the bosses there and
also after i passed my
apprenticeship the ex report got the
hardware store because they allegedly
would have stolen if he was that wasn't true
so i went to the hardware store
sometime weeks later after i finished the
apprenticeship i didn't want to
take over  if I
sent in or out that
I have expanded the h  the detective asked me
on the dishes why is it a miracle he said yes
because they allegedly threw things over the wall
which is nonsense so I
actually when I went through a lot
I didn't do that either the man offered to pick up
the house immediately
that was hermann kriegsfuss has everything
actually started with that i
really liked the training i
felt good too you can imagine
i was in the situation where i had a
lot to lose of course it
was the training i had and
i would have lost it if i had been back
to zero the training
That didn't mean much to me personally
, but he saw it for my
grandparents to say hey I'm
drug-free I'm through now and the
semblance of the so the the
apprenticeship letter then the journeyman's letter topic
from who gets it I've
basically made my grandparents  and
accordingly i have during my
internship before i do the apprenticeship
ng and in the probationary period in the
probationary period it can be terminated very quickly
the training of course every
day 150 percent always give full throttle because
I just
wanted to make a good impression and put this
training place in dry cloths
and after a probationary period
then over  I switched down a
gear but not on the back
burner but still gave 100
percent but only 150
percent I was just out of the probationary period
woman and was a bit
secured because during the probationary period as an
apprentice it's hard to get
fired and then you have
treated me there rome got me so moderately
you don’t go full throttle anymore and
i said as a joke i still give
100 percent but i just fought for the
apprenticeship and i
can’t do 150 percent every day i’m
always there with all my heart 100  percent and
then we have what
therapeutic measures have made mi  ch in
the garden department as a gift that was
the women's department where you wanted to go
and then i just i want yes i
'm not extremely intelligent now
quite the opposite a rascal and i
know my rights and i also know
so knew where it was for me in mine
training i have it ok if i
wanted to find it is no problem
that the sick note came and
not yet a sick note then it will
be six weeks past where i have to
after six weeks of illness yes
to take over the sick ones then i was
back for a day  then and then again in
the six weeks of illness quite simply
and at the end of three years of
training i was written for two years
and how is it going after the training
yes first twiddle my thumbs so i
had since he completed my
training too so i have i  must now
again example now that now
nothing what I so not
recommended to imitate but also mine
I didn't make a decision about my time at vocational school
, I have to admit,
I was already an adult and did
n't feel like
some people were patronizing me and
told me you're
not allowed to drink now and things like that, but I
tried anyway  but I
didn't manage to do it and I
didn't make any effort at all during my working life,
so my school
certificate my best grade on the school
certificate 04 in sports and is also
the only one
for sports above all, but I passed
my training with
an average of 3 or  to practice without making
any great effort and that was
satisfying i had my apprenticeship certificate in my
pocket and afterwards
a bit disoriented
then i worked in the drinks market at the time
because you sometimes get drinks here a job but
never full-time then it should always be 450 euros
or part-time  Yes, that's how it
went, but that was it  by then your
say drug past was already over
that was a really hard
phase drug addiction what that was then
but already forward that was before that but
i also had a few relapses at that time
alcohol played a
problem i also tipped over again at
that time  so not exactly at that time
but a bit during that period
but they made threats in the sense of
what does hard mean and alcohol is also a
very hard drug but what
really broke me before that and
also got me on the street and cocaine
that  Cocaine was really thrown in at
me, which brought
more consequences for the devilish sides
and
ultimately led to my grandparents
with cloud and currently having us around, but
I then had certain phases again
even after my training
but never cheated  so that i did the legal
things, folks, i also
did illegal things
at that time  t but i no longer
stole my grandparents or committed serious
acquisitive crimes still did zappzarap where it wasn't
but on a smaller scale and these drug
phases weren't more than ten years
or eight years but just a
certain period of a year and a half
from the shoot  and then somehow
youtube came as a big rescue for you
yes what does a big rescue mean definitely
yes so when i started youtube and so swinging
i stopped using
drugs but it was
definitely an experience that definitely set
me apart from others  things
definitely stopped now i just
called montana black because of the
spray paint really black numbers and
that means you actually wanted to get
started and graffiti film and
document and then agree here
i created my account
on youtube to
comment on graffiti videos so and so  I
just called myself montana black 88 so
at that time i preferred
or still like to use the
montage black spray cans and 88 my
year of birth like that and then i just have
montana black 88 countries have this
account i don't even know what i
created for them i would be lying now
2011 or something  created correctly and in 2013
2014 i made my first
own videos so in
hindsight it's clear now everyone here says
everyone knows you and montana black monte
now looking back i would
probably have taken a different
name on youtube then
sounds pretty murdered there only at first  cool
story yes that's right there was i know
i there is also corinna bord was like
saying okay well well i would have bought it straight away
as well
there were yes yes but were also with a
headache back then eg when
i met davis as managing director
when the first clothes came out
I wanted to do my own production and I had to secure it legally because you know
there is
already a brand called montana black and that was
just things
but we never had any problems, sometimes
a little greeting comes out and i know
how you would have been in the situation
if you could have done something
legally or probably not  but
nevertheless i never had a
headache with the montana brand with
which montana knows problems was
probably also added value for
you says today are proud
so i need my today for the whole
story yes it's not that i
called myself mentally black  because I
somehow have no idea so it's just
traced back to the spray can is
also good for the decision and
then it started but then I noticed the
graffiti comments on the videos they do
n't really but what because I
only have that I have with this  account
only commented on things I was never out of
it myself to post what the causa count like
this and that just started
wed  t playing again well exactly
right I want the first game what
now but only so the pensioner but then it
was noticed myself that I’m starting
to pulsate what is so could
especially since that was mw3 modern warfare
3 and is that how it came  so you
watched me or like to
watch yourself that you now but yourself or
like modern warfare 3 there was a
feature that hadn't been in any other
call of duty before you could there was
the repeat mode so you could
only do one round for the first time  played
or so you could
watch the game in replay that
didn't exist before and could create the
highlights yourself so let's say
you cooled five people dramatically well in the middle of the round
so
killed in the team the match and that
was a clip that you absolutely
wanted to watch again later, how
you did it and at the end of the day it
lasted a woman so moderately
you could rightly handle it  Cut and
get married and you could do that directly if
you linked your playstation
account to youtube for modern warfare 3 account
you could upload it directly to the
youtube channel and this
function didn't exist before
and that's how I uploaded things for the first time
on youtube without me
wanting anyone to see the
broad masses but i
uploaded it for myself and then sent it to
my colleagues
saying now look here what they have there
later that’s how it is actually
but others have it  seen people and never
actually there not at all but that's
how you took the first step on
this platform so moderately yes and
then we started that somehow
it became a topic for other
people to look at how did you
notice that  the interest there
yes if a video had four views instead of three views all of a
sudden so
see yes there were questions where
do the guys come from and  so that's the
story
I have to say I've told it a hundred times
so it all took its course
they then wrote to
facebook pages that had call
of duty fan pages if they could
post the video there and so it's
really yourself  actively worked to
ensure that the range is created yes yes
yes yes so first of all I
made sure that there was a bit of
range at all, namely with which
he hardly put my girlfriend at the time with
video himself
but otherwise you then
also worked
for people  written that you
might post the video and so
but she will say afterwards
she also says to a different place
that was also just possible at the right time
so back then today it’s
impossible you can’t get in at
all before today so
it is  you have to say look, your
department is now in the special department
, it's not like that on youtube  change you are very thoughtful about the topic
at the top of the
podcast just think about a very
good plausible example of how
you want to see four years five years ago how
few or how many
podcasters there were there were a handful
or two hands full and that was it  now
and that's not bad and
that doesn't sound particularly offended
now every second [ __ ] makes a
podcast the thieves the idea of sensory overload as a
odcast is im
ense on any platform regardless of wheth
r it's on amazon on spotify or or or the r
ght sensory overload of  podc
take place and
that’s exactly how it is now with
instagram accounts and they are
springing up like weeds but back then
when i was in the beginning of 2013 2014 there
wasn’t that sensory overload it
was like podcasts were there 45 years ago
a handful of people two hands
full in the German area who made the good
videos and I'm in the
right place at the right time g  eessentially
because he has since the market was not yet
so oversaturated now is therefore
in all areas completely
oversaturated the people
including me who are very successful
can also use the market for themselves
but someone who has a good idea and
also creative creativity  and also in
talent maybe it's incredibly
difficult to stand out
in any way among all the
overstimulation because it's simple, it's almost
impossible for a channel
to be discovered
overnight because there are thousands of other channels out there  that
's just super super difficult how can the
step from youtube twitter
the step came that was that i
remember so its been yesterday when
i met someone who
played häs lion he also did youtube and also
tisch i no longer have any
contact with either  that hasn't been for eight years nine
years
that was just a companion in the
ze back then  it and he has streams on twitter and
i didn't know what tritsch was i
had about 10,000 subscribers on youtube at the time
and he said do it
i would live stream
trasse to be there tonight i asked him
how do we do it  and we
have skype skype still exists
and at the time was in great demand now
i know almost no one who uses skype anymore
but back then he called me via skype via
video call recorded my
screen and added it to his
stream and i know i do too  was
as excited as a little kid
to see his stream on twitter
when i'm sad it's been so
long i don't
think so i don't think my
gameplay was showing just a
face i know i got mine
stuhl made me look smart
and that's how i was seen on twitch for the first time
that must have been 30 40 viewers right away
maybe and that's
how i'm with swi for the first time  tch came into
contact and when did
you realize that in the end it could now take on
these economic dimensions
this in the last few years
you mean now was the first time i
thought that border works yes what would that be?
that was actually relatively early and that
was  when i was in the decision
or made the decision to
give up my 450 euro job at the
drinks market pick up
yes
because i earned 450 euros a month with all that stuff i have
so
i will say that i am not
grateful where i am now but  I
probably would
n't have had anything against it, knowing what I have now,
if it had stayed at
a few, let's say 1000 euros a
month or something like that, because it just felt like it was easy to
earn your money with this game and your own
Paying rent
or running the
fridge was just a nice feeling
and I now think that
we have a lot more money but that
Conversely, it also means a lot more
responsibility a
lot more headaches a lot more people who
want something from you yes
how do you explain the
successful content back then I already understand
that you were there at the time and I
believe that the fortnight game has
brought a lot again  you hit it, so to speak,
about the timing,
yes, that was his
template for me and for many
other people out there,
a step towards immense success
, but the difference is that many and that
's not meant in a bad way, but
many  people out there we
had demands at times extremely half had extreme
priority
earned good money and as
demands became boring they
also disappeared into
obscurity because it's easy and
your question is now answered the lungs
also want to ask is that's one thing  now
half to produce because of the game the
other is to get this hype u  nd
that people are more interesting to you as people
and that's just
a blessing because i had before the
demanding time but also after it
says that people have always been
very interested in me as a person
god knows why
yes and what is  this why he knows
ask from time to time what nothing but
you are yes your recipe for success
depends a lot on it so how you have your
classic yes maybe have a
particularly small penis
can honestly say i know i
don't know i can't answer that
you don't say don't know
why people want to be so interested in me now
but in the end yes i
don't have any special talent
you just have to say yes but
no special talent i can't hold my
breath for 5 minutes or water or
probably because and  play yourself
you're not the best player now
in most games relatively
[ __ ] yes so what is relatively kaka but
just average  well, i never had a
phase where i particularly shone in the game
and that's why people tuned in. of course
there were games
, i searched a bit and it was a bit okay, but i
wasn't even next to a player or something like that
when i was
I took a look at the classic division and it was clear to me
why it works because it's so
blatantly emotional and passionate
and it comes out so naturally. You do that
too sometimes
many have but now and then there is
an outbreak and something like that that's
also something you want to see but it's
not your thing right now so you it's hard to
grasp if she knows what's going on now there's such
a blatant idea because she doesn't
even  not i can't say it because
it's not
are you worried that it might get in the
way one day so in the
years to come there is no fundamental right  so
the answer would probably
be expected i would like it to
go away a bit sometimes really
yes has a little more peace
fits yes because you somehow say that
people want what you want in the sense
of a year threatens so
that's so like  Should I
formulate it? I don't want it to
go away in the sense that we have fewer
viewers to watch twitter,
I would just like that fewer
people are also interested in me
privately, so privately in the sense of
when I'm on the road it used to
be like that  you've done your thing on the
internet and it's good but
it's really the way it is now
that that was a point where you ca
n't actually go
anywhere properly without people talking to you
and that's okay too but i
'm just human too  sometimes that
for keen on it and sometimes even not
keen on it and sometimes when
you just wish
that one thing closes the other  ere not out
so you just have to if it’s worth a bit
less on youtube
maybe a bit less if
you’re out and about you what that is for
you right now the video platform
the most important platform
yes whereby youtube shouldn’t be
underestimated
either both are both  are
very important independently of each other if i had
to choose a platform now,
i
would like to finally have the
wish that switch or a platform
comes onto the market that
competes with twitter because it's such
a monopolist and so it's a
solitary one  a stand alone platform where
there is no competitor and
yes you always felt like you had to
follow your nephew's little bit so there
were two features that you
would want to change would
you like that appearance we
joke there are so many things that i
change  would that we spontaneously do
too many things even right now  in
my head are to be able to answer this question clearly now
there is so much so petric is a
nice platform no question but since
they were bought by amazon
go in the sea many things have
changed that i don't like
the guidelines how they are interpreted
what terms of service violations is so
what violates the guidelines and
what can lead to an exclusion
for example or so
care if dubai trip
would be permanently banned it means permanently
that for you it is like that for an indefinite
period can be one year two years three years
four  years depending on how clever
you go up to the lawyer against
you but you have to do that in the first three
months
that means for direction is permanently
excluded on the platform you
are not allowed to appear again permanently
on the platform in any way folks  can
watch two of your videos where you can
be seen briefly but I was allowed to if  I'm going
to be permanently banned for kitsch tomorrow
that won't be public, for
example if we're going to
stream it with you right now, they wo
n't be visible and those are
things like that, so I can understand that of
course people are excluded from the platform
and that you  get banned and that's
also certain guidelines but it
's also ergo to share very
emotional pressure when the stepping stones main platform
is a
main source of income your future
share what his family i put you
since me and you always for a moment
what could happen what  it is then
perhaps also unlikely
if you really pay attention but
nevertheless there is a
subliminal pressure that if something
happens sir you will never appear again on this
platform first of
all you have already given cases where you say what you have experienced aha i
demand  I had a
feeling for your target group
employs d  u you really deep the
millions of people
on instagram it looks quite good there they are
more than three million but no
traffic jams or really no statistics
both those of youtube and those of
instagram as well as those of switch is
real in some way because everyone 13 14
year old 15 year old knows how to
create an account when he is 18 so he
can see the 18+ content on
youtube now so
i trust the stats about as
much as twitch does the distribution of
bands
around his question  answer
the average age
people who don't like me would
claim my audience is
twelve to thirteen
kids community the npd don't
take pocket money to go to the casino
but
from to so i have people who are
nine or 80 watching my videos
and i have 60 year olds  how to
watch the videos so
to determine the average age is
relatively difficult but I would
now say that i  I
've been doing the whole thing for eight years and
not many long-term viewers that
you're the
average age or my average old man is the
average age of my viewers
so now we've been around 20
years then it won't be
forgotten that since eight nine  years and
the people are also older but is
still noticeably younger than
themselves best in the end what is interesting well
you that is already a different
target group of
adults i started it when i was 20 a bit later i quickly got the sense of time
in the middle  although one expects to do it earlier
we started around 23 24
that must have been and if there were
viewers we were 13 they
are now 24 I'm 34 because my
average age isn't
anything average age of my viewers is
n't my highlight in 34 meanwhile
I still feel like 18 but the
paper says something else but I think
vi  ele to my viewers are around
20 20 roughly know how much
so my bridge is like that you are also close
with them so you are already
in contact after four minutes and that's
not like it's kind of like
it was at least  you're an influenza
who makes fashion clothes and then
just keeps them in and then
some comments come and won't be
answered you're very close to the
lively community yes that's true but
it's incredibly difficult so it's
incredibly difficult to really
remember names  so as an example now
there is a klaiber function at the peak of the hub
, that means I could support the people for a
fee with five euros a
month and then have
certain extras and no
idea a netflix subscription
but I have it up to date now and there
were more that one  sometimes
not very up-to-date that's 27 thousand people
so how do you want to remember the names of 27,000 people
there are people there who
have been writing to me for 14 months
that's a long time they would have said to me on
the street with their tables
and his brother I
've been paying
eleven-year-old fritz for four years yellow and he
'll say his name I don't know him because they
're joking  that's also human how
do you want to remember thousands of thousands of
names but do you react
somehow one so do you answer a lot of
questions or or are you very interactive there
do you take your time because
we interact with politics or
is that how it is for you  what i do
my thing and the women's questions
always makes me
like i'm trying i'm
trying fine but to
interact with the viewers in the stream i'm
trying to make a healthy mix on the gameplay
a little gibberish of mine answer a few
questions but
and it's okay like that but I
've noticed it again with you
just the beginning the things you tell
me  asks is that was very interesting for
you but that's something I
've told you quite often but that
means the questions are
repeated quite often and you
say little until you get tired of always
answering the same questions but
the answer is less  questions but
then questions that you haven't
answered yet or that you can't
answer in one sentence but
from that a pot worth half an hour
or something just to interact but otherwise
I try to
interact with the viewers sure if
they tell you a lot  different i was allowed to
know so look at your house there you
could see that you
watch other streams yourself we says says what below
delivers live stream i think you can
so i look at who i
am a very heavy consumer of youtube
twitch  regardless of whether I now
react to videos in the stream privately also
a lot of videos
it is also there in phases
which game  just starting is
now for me the
games market is dead, that means i don't
watch any other streamers at the moment
gameplay-wise I've always liked
casino streams they run
in my background every day, it feels like relaxed
when I'm educated myself but
when others come tomorrow calls for 2.0
out or I'm also fully in
the soft inside and pulled every day you can
assume that as soon as I
turn off my stream other stream omnipotence
who gambles the game so that in any
case is also currently the market has so
for me privately shows
little at the moment  because the player doesn't appeal to me
and accordingly there are few
other streamers because everything
I see there from the gameplay is relatively
boring for me and then from time to time I
still do things that go beyond that,
so you should enjoy these little digital
things  two books
written, for example,
so actually bring books and
nothing Bavarian was the  mirror best
list in first place yes that is must do
first i did not get
the
foreign seal but why made books
that is relatively easy to answer
you have several possibilities in
life to process your emotions
for me i think the way of the
more most agreed  would have been
music i think both i as a music
consumer like the pictures where
people process their emotions and
talk about things that happened in their lives
i'm
not on the road musically unfortunately so i've never made
music and probably wo
n't either  make music you do
n't write poetry now either
so for me it was i want to
write a book so it was to process
my emotions what i
experienced back then in a different
way and that's why
i'm determined to do the first one
to write a book from junkie to
youtuber so i have to
say to be fair i have  written by myself
but as you know it in the scene
with the ghostwriter was not at all not
with the ghostwriter was great because they
remain anonymous with what do you call
it then with the car and with the rapid one
then met with me for weeks
sat down for three
hours like right now just
without a microphone we asked questions about
my life took notes and
from that he created the book
they have sold over 100,000 copies
i don’t know the numbers at the moment
but by now i would rather
both say in the direction of 200,000 yes ok and
then the next topic, what you do outside
of verdikt eises, is clothes so
that you've been doing your
own label
for a long time now so the
clothes brand likes to be a level
now i think i give myself
five  years jubilee to five-year
jubilee we're going to i've sold the
clothes before but
then it's been more than that since  en where you
just have your png logo up and they
stick it on a sweater
and that but we have been
doing it independently for five years now produce
ourselves market ourselves ship
ourselves or meanwhile
a company also does it for us
and that is something  I really
like it is not
a how should I say so we
don't try to get
into h&m with money somehow, but
it's just a high quality for the community
with the apple logo and we're
very affine and hamburg on new ones  things
come a lot of products now that have nothing
to do with clothes anymore one
develops further and that is our
so it comes now for example through
trees ok so air trees for the car how
come you have to
ask my business partner yours who came
up with the iss  came by
and put things on the
table for me and said let's try
which one do you like best ri
I haven't tried the best thing and
we also have a lot of people who
drive a car and a village tree like that
, everyone will have a good smell in the
car  it's cool because i know
that things will be bought and of
course at the end of the day also with you
in the podcast or the episodes or with the
people with that especially since in the end it's
always about writing green numbers
we all do it why  because of course you
want to earn money, of course
nobody is lying, so everyone who
claims they don’t do it or
don’t want to earn money is a lie, the question
is how you earn money, and how do
you earn your money
by faxing people and by faxing them the money
pulls out of your pocket or masters in a
cool way with the rhine
conscience which in the end brings money to your account
and fills the fridge and such
a scented tree, for example, is just
just years ago
we wouldn't have thought about
releasing it now you just know it
's a cool
product people will celebrate it we have
fun with the product and if we
end up with green numbers on our
accounts and money  that's why we're
happy the people who buy it are happy
because they get a cool product
so it's a win-win situation for
all of us. victories count for something that's
done in the last few years you say
in retrospect i wouldn't
do such an analyst again  models for
partnerships well
yes of
course there are certain products or
pedro product placements that you did in
the past that you
wouldn’t do like that anymore because
you were maybe even
hungrier back then and were more interested in the one
sum through the
production because you  I had no idea how to
finance a new car,
but I have to say that when I look
at the l  looking
back two or three years now there is actually little
or nothing that i have applied for
which i would feel hard or
say more because i was the
most important partner so what kind of company did you make the
most hot on in the sense of cash or
whether he also probably
probably also the visibility
so of course i'm not allowed to talk about
financial income from partnerships
i would do it but
contractually if i then of course
obligated to remain silent because you
yourself like it with an employer
employee contract that also not
everywhere
i resident  know the question answer differently
every partner who has been by my side for a long time
it is important for me
because i am not looking to work with
companies for a short time
but i always want to work with the companies
alone for as long as possible
jobs a few brands with the  what do you do
with come along I've done it for years
h  at
with gamer sony i've been a
partner for six months or two years now
there are some tvs with whom i
've gained weight for a longer period of time now no longer
because something has changed internally
the budgets have been cut back
but when i'm with a
company  work then my intention behind it is always to work
with him for a long time
because that is also
something that people like about him and the
authentic so i just want to advertise things authentically that i have
also used myself for years yes what
about all the activities for you
now or  also very economical for the platforms
where does most of the money come
from above
i hope the big ones can play
there but still have to
so you play on that
we also do a podcast together as you do
that and we are allowed to do it as a
production partner with the way
actually you  it's always very
different, so in december it's
youtube, for example, because the cpm is very high
ch is,
you can't do that like that, it
's different, sometimes it's the
month of the partner, i.e. the site, but at the
end of the day it's clear youtube and
twitter are my main sources of income
when it comes to social media platforms,
we talk a lot there too  nice more often
about made public about
hundreds of thousands of your month come
in in december large sums come in because of
course in december the advertising budgets will
all want to be so
probably high christmas business
is also right it's like in the
individual also there everyone makes the most
sales
hundreds of thousands of euros i don't do it
every month via youtube and wedges no
you have to say the numbers I
say they also moto you can also give
half directly to mama
merkel or now to barschels
a papa schulz
but of course there is also a
six-digit sum  even
now if you put youtube and twitter
together
when i jet  currently I can answer the question
honestly here now youtube and
twitter are currently maybe just under
100,000 a little over 100,000 gross
I would say I'm not looking at it at all right
now but it's definitely
significantly less than in December
little is always a gripe on a high
level clear but please people
shouldn't think that I make
hundreds of thousands of euros every month with
youtube & witsch that's just
not the case but if you
could also increase it you do
n't seem too interested
in increasing your earnings urgently  you're
not that close now either you're doing quite
well and you can do everything
you wish for when you look over the
garage you need to
clean up everything looks pretty good too
the lambo
up front had paid for it
so  that means you're not now
why the maximum or are
on the road maximum no no no so I
'm never up  of maximum maximization
because i once had a phase
where my business partner could be the
driver three years ago or yes
about 34 years ago i always said to him
de we have to know the product
here and there a lot more if there is
a  half a year is now
running much more deeply relaxed
while I do my thing is running and
if it will be over in a year
then a year will be over but I do
n't
have to mix the q all at once I think it's even better
if you  lets a bit of time
go by because i don’t have
to stop with all that stuff for the next two years
and so far it’s
going the way you did it but can you imagine
it’s somehow 19 15 years so it’s
going in  ten 15 years i would be in my
mid-forties early 50s
no idea i'm doing you can
imagine doing a podcast in 10 15 years
i'm posting  I'm just following and
I think my biggest concern is that
my curiosity is waning, it's
just not like that anymore and now I
just want to know about the now or in general
and when that's gone then it's
all over for me and that's why I
can do it  that's why I'm happy with you
now you can do it and is there
interest in it my topics
would be interested in it economy
always remains an interesting area the question
is can you, so to speak, as a person
much more important for me
the guest is much more important you are yes  basically
the star so you can otherwise then is
your star role or as long as you want
so that's relatively difficult to
answer i'll see what's
in store for me in 10 15
years
but you're right the one who has a
thirst for knowledge has to be there that  was
also a small problem for me so
now not a big problem but I've
actually already played through both youtube and twitter so it
there's just a book made when there are
no new challenges on this
platform at the moment that's why i
already said i would appreciate it
if a competitor platform
appeared maybe also on
youtube but also access because then
you would have assumed the
platform would change  or the platform
would like to have you and
pay a certain transfer fee, like in football,
that you switch and the platform is
cool because you would have new excuses
there are always new challenges in life
to create and
these challenges are currently on
twitter and youtube  relatively limited whether
you are a ticker for something like that then it is
really relevant yes i am on the go
abona mattick and but look there but
he is not actively using a platform now
so has two million followers
otherwise not coming for a while
old clips i had uploaded
but as of now no platforms that are
in focus for me s  I'm actively involved in
games, quite the opposite, I'm even
so I've even warned tik tok by a lawyer,
so if action was taken against them,
why, well, because this is
a platform that didn't have a reasonable
reporting function, well, that's it, I
have my business
partners  yes my managing director name
i pushed my clothes to whether deals
and old and on everything but it
i have someone else
sebastian clever is called yes it is in the
youtube network so is my youtube
network manager and if now
for example you upload a video
tomorrow at  1 p.m.
and no idea there is
my address or
data from my grandparents was he was
then i can have this video deleted within two minutes as soon as i
see it or it is sent to me
it goes away immediately and
it’s the same options  I have it on
instagram on twitter because you have a
collection and it's also important that
this platform is the  se have the
opportunity because privacy both of
private individuals but also of
people in public public life
is very important that you can
act against it and
tito didn't have this possibility was on tik tok so people
uploaded videos of other
people
with private information and
these videos  were then taken offline after 345 days
after the
million news got and
spread and accordingly
I took legal action
because I didn't see why
a platform tik tok might
break something for me such as
privacy tub and that's why  i
want it to be generally if you know that too
researched in the terms and conditions under
the guidelines for functionality on the
platform extremely deep down so
now you look pretty much exactly what can
you do what the the juze button
is there for guidelines so you are
you now  not just someone who d
it was okay like that they do it that way i do
it and now you look pretty closely at
who sad if not i've been doing this
for eight nine years now i have to
know so there was
definitely a time when i wasn't that into
it  was and I'm not that into
foreign trade but now
I know where I am what I'm allowed to do what
I'm not allowed to do where is it to be
fair I've had
enough headaches on
entering the platform I've
had enough headaches enough palaver 33 days on the train and
and  and hermann wester was tired before that too
he wasn't up for it anymore
i'll always be someone who's a
bit controversial and always not
so politically 1a correct and sometimes
likes to drop the son of a [ __ ] so
if someone says openly go but i'm
older too  you
shouldn't forget that either so i
started the whole thing with that we have 24 34
and i'm just tired from
these headaches so tired the close
to get back what are you doing a lot of
investments are what he is already a
bit on the way or are you looking at
everything so how are you doing an
investment
crypto i don't know what you mean without
yes i bought two apartments come
me my house here
bought one or  other very chic
fetched me because marc gebauer really
right and otherwise
i invest a lot in the tax office
so here is a lot my biggest
investment is currently
what are you really not worried about
or exact plans are right otto
i have to make provisions somehow
buy first actually  etf or
invest in the stock market or put some
into the world trade so what
money is just a thing that is of
course important but also
comes in regularly and
yes of course you should
invest in certain things and that’s what I
did as I said about the apartment
fetched the house and rebuilt
it
and if at some point again e
there is
a certain financial buffer and a certain financial leeway where you
say you have planning 50,000 40,000
30,000 to 200,000 euros left and you
would like to invest
in your property is whether it was in shares but
then i'm ready for it so you
're welcome to put my money in here  things where a
promising future
for me
they say yes so where I see potential
but currently as I said I had to
pay a lot of back taxes it's
okay I knew that too so
I knew what to expect posted
over a million recently
even  enough yes a total of 1.5
million was paid i paid that
does of course first of all as i knew
that and everything is fine so there is
nothing that i thought about overnight
oh my god so much taxes
good tax consultant of the vaart
said march  that's up to me i knew
that but
you have to if you pay such a sum
then of course you deserve it too of course
but i have  we put half a million
into the conversion of the house
we made just before that are also stupid
mistakes if i
can talk to you openly and honestly it would have been a stupid
mistake i made because
i have both the conversion of the house
here almost everything  only paid in cash or everything out
of my own pocket plus i got the two condominiums
that are 900,000 euros which i
paid in cash so by bank transfer stop
and liquidity is very important and
now in hindsight two years
later three years later it would
certainly have been easy  relax be able to
get credit because the quality on the
account and 900,000 euros was just a lot of
money what what was spent
that's why it's more like
the plan now save a
little again first of all stay because
with the tax office the things are closed
pay have to be paid that's what
I did, in 3 23 months there will be
another advance payment and so
the üb  lich but what is important first of all is a
little money again, the open for
business so if you say ok now i
'm interested like there are quite a lot of
brands just talked about
coro in the preliminary talk because you said
we know ourselves whether you buy larger quantities
and  so you can really help to
create immediate sales for many brands
yes that is true currently
one is more in that direction so of course
one is always available for cooperation
but currently he is so
focused on doing his own things bringing his own products
whether  it's now in the scent tree
or other things i
can't talk about yet first focus always
bringing your own products up
to date and let's
just say company doesn't chorus
euro comes and they have great so
they have great product and everything is
promising
then  i would most
likely not say
hey we can do something together give
me ten months 20 mm  month and I'm
applying that should then I'd say
okay we can do it but how many
relatives does he give me that for the
new game is really also with
people of his size in the proportion to
ask yes that hasn't
worked out yet or  so
far i haven't asked that so often
but it would go more in the direction
yes because company shares
are more promising in the end than the sum of
iks per month well you look at what
others are doing so if she is
somehow nice now david is doing somehow
brought a tea or chapter and so
that i know that you the market is
so it's your turn to look yes then he
finally comes my tea you put
pressure on your manager here says at some point
the
tst
won't come from me and that's
so it would be natural too  what's cool
no question monti yes then also
who that would have been then the name was
n't as if we didn't
even talk about it but yes it  there is
already a lot that is up to date it is
not just the viola by kapital brach
which was very successful but many
others have also brought out
drinks or iced tea
but of course you know the market you
get it and i don't
look at it i'm happy for  the fact that it works for them
and that it works
successfully above all things and
that good salespeople do it is also
something good for me because you notice
that the broker or the people
behind it who buy it accept it,
so people out there who see you on the
internet  celebrating celebrating but also
bringing out cool products video also opens
a few doors for me knowing that
generally with such friendship in the
scene so she told me he
is infinitely grateful because without you he
would never have become so successful never
grew so big  so close so
simply told that you can also
help other people i know you're
somehow with 187 so here this and
co quite closely  is it a bit of a
give and take because there is a real
friendship like bux tier just accept
and choose when do you feel or
how guessed well
you really know a lot of people
in that area
yes how should i put it you know a
bunch of people but very few  there
are also people
i would invite to my house now
i know how to do so i know
lots of people and i'm also cool
with them and and if you meet
mw at an event then
you snap you write on instagram but
you should  definitely keep his circle
because otherwise you can go
to 30 weddings at the same time that
doesn't work and i
've met a lot of people through the scene with
whom i also have a friendly
relationship yes and
yes what can i say about that but
if you know  that you yourself
have systems in your delusion, too,
people who bring
people forward to push people's careers at the end
too  to build and you could
probably make a label and how you
yourself develop people who
yes but that would be like opening your own
label so I don't make
music open your own label and
pull influenza or instagram admira out of the ground
and be successful  to do that would be something
that is not in my interest,
that without a technical brand that
theoretically everyone comes to me,
regardless of whether you think it's cool or
not, sign with you moderately and
then somehow had to make it
successful by hook or by crook  and the
people by my side were
rossi, for example, so that
the 1000 2000 viewers don't even get to know each other like that i
thought the kohl helped a bit
and yes he probably wouldn't
be where he
is today if he wasn't me  if i
hadn't supported him but that is
anyway would have bicycle chain who
knows what would have happened in his
life with se  in his career
but i supported him because i
liked him or like him as a person and not
because i
somehow saw money in him for
me he was clear i'm still
waiting for my rolex which he was supposed
to push me over one day i
probably would  Waiting 100 years
is okay too, but otherwise you know how big the
team actually is, so if you
now imagine that team monte that
's just and how many people you have a
hangover has what manager how many people
say you work
on my team, agata also belongs
understand my housekeeper so i
hired myself now place as a
montana black i hired
three people full time and they are
qatar housekeepers and if yes or no
my manager put
me up to be full
business partner
i hired my cat agatha
and big  mac said moderator
comes from the
fact that one I can't tell you that
the other next to where that came from  come on ok
i have never seen to date
seriously not i have never heard a
span of him i dont know
how his looks or his
voice has changed but he has
been with verse for 23 years and i have known
him for 9 years and why  one
no longer has the impulse he
wants to remain anonymous on the internet
almost big mac and that's not
it for me there are many who would like to do something like that for
you definitely yes but you
[music]
i deserve a lot  But money
doesn't grow on trees for me,
so you're fun too,
not very economical, but full-time
employees cost a lot of
money, it's not just them
who get the wages, but there's
also that, we'll do it again, Merkel does the
hand  so let's assume I've
now found 1 4100 euros a month, the costs
don't end up but run up to
almost 30 and that's how it is and accordingly I
'm not looking for n  oh new
work or how much already are you
as an onliner watching and being active yourself
what comes through the
day sometimes it's
different at 10 sometimes 17 hours on the
pc sometimes twelve hours sometimes just
two hours it always depends on what
you do privately  are you sitting on the road with
the boys or or he doesn't know
witches privately would my old friend
be it from school
yes i still have my old boys
like five years ten years ago my
side of course you have so there are also
friends with the  you just have so much
contact you got into
arguments he was like money there is also but
my colleague simon he
had two children now
it's clear so i still
meet him a few days ago on
the way but of course  the 24
year old we would all be grown up all my
boys from before went the normal way three times got
work exactly and normally they
have  less time for home is
also for chilling is taken care of again what
do you think such a
dimension so you even asked something different
like the thought one day
do i have to be employed somewhere
for money to do something normal classic
sense work or is that  for
you so that won't happen
because i'm very through and a little
bit but that's going to be ongoing with
social media insofar as you like or
can you imagine one day
had to be 9 o'clock in the morning again
that she has my destiny for
be ready i have no
influence on it i earn good money
i can pay my bills i
have money in reserve
which is always a point
which many others underestimate too much
it just has what you always have at the end of the day
and at the end of the year  have to hand it over to the
state again that's a
lot of money and if you ask me now
if i could have taken care of it i
I can't answer your question like
that because I don't know exactly what
taxes will come in the next
1,200 because you know someone you
always have you will so now it
's 2022 and I won't pay for 2022
until the end of 2023  3 it's a bit late
but i'm still hungry so i
haven't earned enough money
yet to say i'd like to
retire now and at the end of the day it's not
always just about earning money i.e.
the pure sum but it works
also about the projects that we are still on
site and me and my business
partners have planned many more cool projects, which of course also
means if we are successful that you
earn money but a few projects
were tree it is i won’t say anything about it so
i can’t comment  film or
say something like I said no other you
should now back up on rtl reporter
moslems don't get out of the street to
ask the public  because there
are a lot of classic media that
you are no longer so good at talking to
on rtl, for example these gossip and
gossip things are just dirt because
they always really watch you like
paparazzi because they
just always have the word in their mouth
turn and you can tell me if
that's nice that people are following you
with the camera and that he's
what rascals from rtl then
standing in front of my door and tell me
young pensioners don't talk to us and
let's see about their
grandparents so if he  that's what
i send it to because
you're so mean to me that you
go to my grandparents who
are most important to me who bother me what
kind of reaction is expected or that i
shake hands with you
the interpersonal just has to
be right the human  Respect
is something that is very important and you
can definitely see the video
where they are at sido's door so
and d  u can't say that
the interpersonal relationship is bearable in any way
how these
idiots behaved in front of sido's door
the com private to his
door and he says several times they go and they
don't go and ask him whenever i'm
in sido's situation  would have been i
think i'll get through it again he's been
felled it's still
calm and funnily enough these
reporters always take it
upon themselves to talk to people who just don't open their mouths if you have any reporters she's the the abuja chaplain for example
then once again put the question down
then comes before the stop the face
missed and slopes that also
in most cases like that and why should
i like that they are from
rich people and that was just easy back
then with rtl they drove after me in the car
asked which people in the city center and
and that was so yes i just ca
n't stand it i can stand it  if you if
you wanted to bother me ok that's
one thing but that's what got
me thinking if they tell me
we're going to go over to their
grandparents now it's not possible that
's not possible and then you'd be mad
as well  do you see the media yourself so
do you watch every gesture but
little spiegel.de bild.de do you watch
something else how do you consume your
everyday politics so to speak
i detest
bild
spiegel okay maybe a
bit better but in general
all this media [ __ ]  it's really big
but we have to know somehow what's going on
so we don't get almost
anything anymore i neither
watch the news nor am i somehow the only newspaper who reads the book or the daily newspaper
and i've only been reading
the blue light article for ten years now
to look at what the criminal
boys got out of my skin so everything really
it really
concerns politics i don't know i
get it  not always what it
sounds very egotistical
and not everyone will encounter this game
either. i don't care
what happens when i know everything is just
so fast-moving today, tomorrow, of
course you get certain things
with you but at the end of the day before  the
kukksi sport sport sport
follow of course but it
wouldn't be the transfer likes the news like
that I don't like soccer yes but what's
happening in the world now of
course you notice certain things
but and that sounds very
egotistical but I'll watch a few things in front of mine  front door
happens and in my environment and in
my town and what happens elsewhere
you might get that with
me yes well i
don't watch tv in the sense
of rtl or rtl2 or something like that i watch
my nature documentary show or massage
luxuria they have to watch it  christmas a
cd i can't watch it because
then i always have to
watch certain documentation
but  as soon as a
gazelle is eaten by the lion
i quickly put away the
teary eyes that's not okay but
there are 1000 inquiries from
tv production companies see what
we want to do
yes of course but also others
now try it out or wax it of
course nothing  the subject of television
made klaus i was wondering if
i would go jump to the tower with him
so it was exactly
with joko and klaas or something
like that my management dennis has already received a request
who knows where
which requests come from tv
comes with a lot of requests but
i will stop  just don't
forget i was at stern tv yes you were
your grandparents there then a selection such
a prestige think stern tv is so
i didn't regret going there at the end of the day
it's
still rtl but the production team
behind it  is a different one so it's
just right and stern tv
just has this on for the
grandparents  otherwise i don't forget that
all these media like rtl or
also prosieben and what they all are called
made fun of us earlier and
earlier that one point and the other
point is
i know should i be on tv so what
should
i keep people there  Yes, but I can
still entertain people via my platform.
I really would like to have the
rtl2 audience or the rtl
audience, which somehow hangs there 24/7 every day
and watches families in the focus,
honestly, it's not like
that, I don't know, television, so I see myself on the
television area yes but not in the
classic television rtl 2 vox maneuver
but then more like netflix amazon
area think for me this is the new
time television
but for sure there are also one
or the other format in television in the
classic television where i would also
say okay
I don't like the station as such, but
I like the format, so
it was the one just before I jumped
it off  he heard a quick twitch about the race what
don’t you really want to
do
high diving rossi asked me and
it would have been a cool
opportunity to maybe
shake
stefan raab’s hand i love stefan raab i have
to admit it’s stefan raab i don’t know him that
privately  so i can only
talk about what we all saw on
tv and maybe 12
background information about that everyone was
in close contact with raab on their show or atom
, but for me
stefan raab is simply
a kind of role model in terms of
entertainment  concerns who also
likes to be rubbed off and no platform
has spoken up my dream back then
was always to sit totally on
tv then unfortunately this show will be discontinued and
this dream will no longer come
true the new tv
will now be available again with the new one  moderator
yes but that is so
i'll give you a typical monte example
tv total with stefan raab was a full one
r high
politics in sexual intercourse that
was what i liked
and the new tv total is in a half-
filled sack with half erections
also work in sexual
intercourse but not what i prefer tv total with stefan raab is the only
original there is where i  would
have been nice because simply
stefan for me simply simply for him for
the tv area simply that's now
listening to this here and then says okay I'll sound
through and will persuade herself to
manslaughter then she'll come no then she
won't be alone anymore  just because
someone calls me like stefan raab
invites me to do it still won't cuddle jumping around
like
that isn't necessarily
mainz what i see for me where
i'm at was accepted as an example
now wok wm or crash came that's
where i me  inside is coming when that
comes so that the packers would be just
so you understand that's not now
I hope he hears that it's like that but
high diving is also  just not
authentic for me you can
definitely have fun but it's not where
i see myself it won't suit me the
way things are
but with car speed he's
the one where i would see myself well
so many many thanks for that  typical
monte open conversations like no
no platform and i'm extremely
excited it goes on i find it
somehow i think i also recognized a bit
that the
attractiveness comes from what people now
why it works so openly until
and because it's also on the shelf  well
this this casualness you have to have
that means it doesn't matter but i
never wanted to become more
people on the internet that people asked me
to become, i always wanted to
be who i am and that's what i
did i don't play an actor
and so you understand me  my like other
people
thanks a lot
[applause]
[music]